I'm gonna quote mr. Winkler when
President Obama was elected in November
2008 the US economy was shrinking at a
rate unmatched since World War two in
the seven years between then and his
final State of the Union address which
takes place tonight global investors
have enjoyed stellar results from the
rapidly expanding obama economy and
central bank intervention there was a
little of that the Fed always helps and
they certainly contributed to this but
the real story here is that if anyone
told you seven years ago that the
American economy and in particular
American companies would outperform
their global peers in 2015 by a
considerable margin in fact do so better
than they've done at any time really in
the 21st century you have to go back to
2001 that would have been sort of
laughable that those analysts who say
momentum is now out of a market now that
we're looking back at fundamentals
companies aren't doing so well look at
where they're trading look at what
earnings were third quarter laughs
that's actually misleading because as I
said if you think about what Jim press
said yesterday to you about where Toyota
is largest car maker in the world
guess what market they're excited about
the US market the fact is that when you
look at America today in American
industry today 10 of the world's largest
companies in the world 10 out of 10 are
American you have to go back decades to
find something comparable to that that
doesn't happen by accident it happens
because there's a lot of activity the
three most important industries the ones
that have outperformed in the past seven
years consumer discretionary companies
technology in finance all of those
things are pillars of an economy that is
doing well Matt what do you make of
timing governor Carney came over to the
UK and his timing was amazing we were
talking at the time before he came under
Mervyn King they were voting for more QE
some of the policymakers were at the
Bank of England and it was just the
right time where things just started to
go higher things just turned out right
how much is luck a factor
in the Obama economy when you look at
the fact that actually stepped into
things where the market was actually
just bottoming about three months later
and also shell was taken off because
it's very easy to forget the balance
sheet of the Federal Reserve doubled
output in terms of energy oil production
also double their two huge factors that
he had nothing to do with okay so I'll
be the first to say better lucky than
smart and I always have believed that
having said that you make your own luck
and let's go back to the first year of
the Obama administration there were two
things that were done that were
signature achievements of the
administration one the rescue of the US
auto industry which was very
controversial at the time turned out to
be a very good investment when you look
at where we are today
last year American automobile sales were
at a record okay the second thing was
the stress tests okay getting the
financial system in order at the time
April of 2009 people were very skeptical
in the financial industry in particular
about the stress test it turns out once
they were imposed and they succeeded the
confidence in the American financial
system began and you saw the rally by
the way in American stocks begin at the
bottom of March 2009 it's been continued
ever since Julie want to show us
something about unemployment there from
the Bloomberg yes exactly this is if you
look at another sort of marker of the
progress that we've made in the economy
you see the jobless rate of course is
something that the administration has
pointed to as a source of pride so you
see the previous comparable cut in the
jobless rate happening in 1989 and now
you see the cut in half that we've had
since 2009 as we've recovered from the
recession and from the financial crisis
great thanks man I just want to push you
a little bit this is your grade is the
optimist of the Stephanie said it's a
great idea it's a great idea of all the
guests yes exactly
but some might say okay terrific great
tracker for eight years but we didn't
really build for the future that we
didn't take care of infrastructure that
the first stimulus bill was really
inefficient that we didn't take care of
long-term entitlements problems and so
we
totally had a great eight years but
looking forward we bought ourselves a
whole lot of trouble for the next 10 15
years I think all of that is true but I
would say that a couple things have
happened in the past 7 years that have
put the United States economy in a very
good position to take advantage of
things that you're talking about like
infrastructure one the budget deficit
declined from 10.1 percent
to 2.4 percent okay that is the biggest
favorable reversal in at least 50 years
we've never seen a favorable reversal
like that for the budget deficit and if
you recall in 2009 2010 2011 that was a
big topic of concern okay so that's one
big obstacle removed from the table the
second thing is the unemployment rate is
five percent okay and it did come down
from 10.1 percent and it's gonna come
down even more and so people are going
back to work finally interest rates are
very very low these are the best rates
in a generation or two for people to
borrow so if you want to build bridges
and tunnels and all that sort of stuff
this is as good a time as ever you're
gonna get you had somebody on Bloomberg
Television earlier this morning Adam
Posen talking about now is as good a
time as any to invest in infrastructure
it's exactly what government should do
that's actually a growing consensus
around the world